here we got some stuff to do today um to
start off
here taking a look at this environment
and seeing if I can get this to run fast
had a a request to look at this this is
as you can see a pretty old project and
um I don't know if we're going to even
be able to get this to build but we're
going to try
like there's probably a reason they said
to not use this
but okay
it says this installs
let me get this so my camera is not
covering
here oh yeah they got a lot of games in
here
games oh they even have like cqu Quest
that's
cool I'm trying to think what the
easiest way to get this to uh to build
is going to be
Java and see if I can figure out how
this
here uh that's no good also where' my
chat
go I just saw the message watch your
disertation video awesome work thank you
let me fix I don't know why my chat
isn't uh is not showing
here oh there we
go wrong overlay thank
you I have a new one on the uh the r
Iceberg video it's a much more updated
and um very thorough overview of the
space of RL and sort of what's Happening
yeah this is kind of rough trying to
figure this
I'm trying to think like if there's an
easy way I can get this T this thing to
what uh I think that this got taken over
right yeah this got taken over
let me check that message don't hey
linky
so uh I mean this is a new one
right I uh I'm trying to figure out how
to compile this project to see if I can
do some cool stuff for Julian and uh I
think that their domain got taken over
because it points to a beding site now
yeah this is this says that they're
docks yeah this gu taken over 100%
bastards drop the link I'll D well it's
here it's gvg
i.net let me find it yeah gvg
a.net I don't want to if I put it in the
you I could DM it to you
on yeah I'm pretty sure if I put it in
the YouTube like it'll get
flagged yeah I don't know if they like
just bought the expired domain or they
took it over though that's ridiculous
either way
2.3 why don't I see this edit anywhere
here oh
here two player track
okay I'm trying to think if there's any
way I can even get like a
container that would be able to run
mean if I can figure out the Java side
like there's not that much python I can
probably just rewrite
it because these are all just text
files right that's the point of the
thing cant Source yeah see this is all
oh there's a little bit of
python okay there is a little bit of
python in here
let me see if I can figure out why it's
not like running the
command and
such let me see if you're dming me stuff
as well on this because that's
ridiculous like I don't want Julian's
lab to deal with that that's nuts that
they have to have if somebody's like
pulled their domain
Imports what if I do
this oh this actually
runs hold
on I'm kind of surprised I'm sure we're
going to have other errors but
okay so we know that this we know what
this is
though cool so let's
um let me just start like making an
actual binding for perer for this
linky if you got updates on Pokemon I'd
be all ears I've been uh I'm not even
going to say busy lately I've just been
like exhausted with all the stuff I've
been uh juggling here so I haven't had
as much time in the evening to check on
stuff well or rather I haven't had the
I've just been basically crashed there's
a lot of cool stuff happening though
and we're very very close to shipping
some uh some new stuff on
puffer
[Music]
R what's like a basic one herei
great
progress in Victory Road geez
Safari Zone working okay
awesome and what is it getting stuck at
Victory Road like what's up there
strength script I
see so probably if you just fix that
strength puzzle it'll do
it for policy collapse uh send me link
me graphs of um of a run I can look at
it and see if I see anything
there's no way to deal with this is
there
oh I forgot I got to change I got to set
the mic filters for today right yeah
there we go that'll gate out all
the add on that welcome you folks as
well uh we're doing something a little
different just for a bit today uh I
have I asked
Julie if I could help at all with RL
stuff wondering if puffer
could so this is a really old project
project get it
building this is uh the
something I it's scripting
language
developing really bad all right here one
sec
better does this still cut or are we
good I have Construction in the
background and I don't want you all to
be listening to that right I just have
to get the the noise clip
filter actually hold on I should be able
to set this channel to monitoring seems
better
okay well if if it still sounds weird
let me know and I'll do a little audio
monitoring quick but I don't want to
break momentum on
up this should fail
right so this fails because of
scipi so what we're going to do is we're
just going to
set move this dependen see
this packages
GB I
Zelda and we'll leave all this stuff for
now
that okay so you actually have to
specify the M name we're going to do is
we're just this
to Zelda
oh I
install there we
this ah wait this is gym not gymnasium
right so what we need is we need to use
gy
here then we're going to have to wrap
this I
guess okay cool so now we get the scipi
misk
error and we can actually go and fix
this
suffer puffer Rhymes it's actually
really funny uh you know my buddy will
thought he was coming up with a cool
insult he's like he said yeah puffer lib
suffer lib so I said okay thank you
you've just given me a great slogan you
know don't suffer use
puffer just giving me more
ammo that's how we roll
welcome
K folks on YouTube um if you're not
following kyung on Twitter and you do
anything in robotics or control space
you're missing out kyung is doing
awesome awesome stuff in control space
with
puffer try to come up with Jack stuff
too oh dude I have so many for Jack at
some point like I'm going to do some
meme post on this uh here this is what I
have in
mind
guy we're going to use this as a meme at
some
point it's going to be say no to Jack
kids something like that
yeah pretty
nice it's only getting
better what we're currently doing here
is we are uh we're attempting to fix
this old Java
project um like a precursor to Gridley
but it has a whole bunch of games
once all right what's the replacement
for IM re like that matches exactly
are people trying other games on P
boy uh I mean that's the main one on P
boy now we could do
that we kind of need it to be a bit
faster
though like 7K is Not Enough by modern
standards right we're doing it for
Pokemon because of like you know it's
such a cool thing really 7K is like 7K
vectorized is not going to get it for
for RL for where I want to take the
field at
least like once you get into the tens of
thousands maybe you can do something but
really like come on give me 100k plus
minimum
and actually like slow
minimum and actually like slow environments are going to get even worse
environments are going to get even worse
when we go to
multi site was bought on March 15th year
by a German company
that's why you got to have your domains
Auto
renewed I almost screwed up I almost
lost the puffer GG domain because of
like authentication issues but I got it
and I renewed it now we got puffer
GG very nice
all right
so that actually made an end
right so do we have a we have a rapper
for this don't we like gym to gymnasium
or whatever
I think it's in
rappers like one of the convenience
things that we do for people is we uh we
distribute rappers
gymnasium I don't even know if this one
will work though to be honest with how
old this is we'll
we
even used to writing
okay probably the defaults are insane
right
crazy batch size will be 1024
maybe
batch
six M's can
what the
heck
90 oh okay
this is fine we just need to uh we just
need to edit the network a little
one so we have this like convolutional
default policy
here has some options that you
handle whatever we
is frame stack is four because it's four
channels or whatever uh we'll have to
double check on that
and do uh channels last equal
two last
through and then flat size we'll have to
compute I pass channels last so let's
see what happened here
hey K have you seen uh I'm not sure if
you're here have you seen puffer GG
yet this is our little uh our latest
little page for these
environments you can literally just go
online and play these
immediately the AI teammates are pretty
dumb so far we have to retrain them in
some such but they're pretty cool
nonetheless there are a c first couple
of
C so for some reason this Channel's last
variable is not getting
Set uh that doesn't make any sense to
me
policy oh cuz I'm dumb that's
it oh . SSO do
image a little concerned it's uh reading
and writing to
file we'll have to look at what it's
doing
there okay so here we have 4 by 90
right no downscale Factor
not be multiplied that's fine we know
what this error
is but when you take a combo
policy uh you have to figure out the
dimension you like
this will tell us the dimension of the
uh the post convolution
filters so here you can see we have uh 8
64 7 and
12 quite a lot isn't
it decent starting point
though this goes to
seven go to 12
this go
away yeah warning goes away it looks
like environment does not
suppor fine
that
is ridiculously
it that is
painful
welcome YouTube
folks currently doing uh this AI this
video game description language we're
seeing if we can get it to be decently
fast and Puffer I doubt it because it's
like really old and written in Java and
not optimized but uh I wanted to at
least do an initial thing for Julian's
lab just to see if uh we can help them
out at
DOI
do M creator
all right and then we'll do profile
emulation see if this does anything for
us it looks like they're writing the
images to file or something like that is
kind of bizarre
it oh it's gy Dash uh it's
gy
and I think I just called it g AI I'm
wrong about this here we
go
okay so this is now
38.3 steps per
second
um no way
right no way it's that
joke let me just double check that thing
from before
SSO hi what are we doing today this is
uh G gii it's like this cool older
package that's used for essentially it's
like a a description language for lots
of different games has 160 different
games in something like that we're
seeing if we can get it to run at a
reasonable speed with puffer I don't
necessarily expect that this will go
well because it's very old and written
in JavaScript uh I mean Java not even
JavaScript but
um I wanted to do this as like an
initial thought process
yeah see how this
goes I have some initial
metrics this is
the the
thing SSO
serializable State
literally communicating images by
writing them to dis isn't
wrong R Json I think it's literally
writing observations to
dis I mean there's unoptimized and then
there's
this oh wait wait maybe not let me
see Act
start there
Step know what this image
is I guess it's updating the image in
place or something
weird I don't know know that's very odd
either way
though let me run a slightly longer test
just to make
sure I don't want to tell Julian like
hey this thing is crazy slope it's not
that
bad we'll run a longer test
though I know this is
accurate that's insane
okay well
it maybe there's a way to
like cuz technically if it's going to be
if it's going to be like disio bound or
something weird maybe it paralyzes
what oh I need to test uh batch size
right I need to change the batch size
the scaling doesn't seem quite possible
to me though because it shouldn't be
able to scale more than 24x but maybe
it's because the disc iio is like full
async I guess that's like
possible I mean that's like so far
outside the realm of what I even
consider designing this stuff though I
mean writing images to dis observations
that's
all right that's more in line with what
I with what I would expect that's like
little over 10x
right why is it only trying these
options why is it only trying these two
options
python maybe if I can just not have the
this
option uh
oh maybe if I just not if I don't see it
or something
I get
today not
make I don't think I am seting though
that so we have this nice autotuner
if I don't know why this thing low today
I guess it must just be Network
here see what happens run this they give
us some information I think it's just
getting hidden by all this deprecation
nonsense again this is like a a six or
seven year
old this point
oh probably I just need to set there to
be more total
environments should do that
automatically really should do all this
automatically
okay there we
go
oh B size is one yeah yeah yeah I know I
just have the settings wrong
fine why is vim quitting so like all
these programs
oh Jee Java
why is Java spinning all my
course maybe this environment is not as
slow as I thought maybe it's just
um know maybe it's just the doesn't have
clean terminations or
well there now it's not spinning stuff
at
course why was it spinning all of my
course have internal
vectorization something is weird it
shouldn't be multi-threading
this actually I guess I should check the
uh this repo it would be in here
somewhere
g n
maybe game level
version no there is no option to
vectorize in
here no option to
and batch size of 24
maybe see how fast this can get
it so what we're doing
here is we're running a puffer lib
automatically uh what ER will do
automatically it'll do a whole bunch of
profiling uh it will do a whole bunch of
profiling and it will tell us which
settings when we're running multiple of
these in parallel it'll tell us how many
environments we should run in parallel
how many per core etc etc and it will
automatically find the best settings
for I a little bit concerned looking at
this core
I this is not using all the cores
effectively puffer lib is usually very
very good at
that I think there's something very odd
going the Java
side Java
code oh that's a step up from
before big step up from before actually
okay now you can see all the cores being
loaded
correctly this crashes the Box though
not going to be
happy 44 gigs of
we just have to hope that the Box
doesn't go
down and that's capping the whole Ram of
the
Box 32 I don't know what it is
doing this is not my code this is a six
or seveny old Java project that is using
all the RAM on the box um which is funny
because puffer lib is actually designed
in most cases to detect and prevent you
from doing this I'm probably going to
just kill this before it kills my box if
it's not already too
late yeah I can't do
anything there's a good chance this
takes the box
down uh oh there we go h
that one of those
codes
yeah it's an old project
no here we go what we're going to we're
just going to apply a little bit of a
limiter on
this
um was
it8 times not going to that is
My Hope Is that um even though the
environment is really
slow it's like I'm assuming the Java is
not that right Java is slow but it
shouldn't be that slow I'm assuming that
most of this overhead is coming from
like really dumb communication between
Java and python
uh and if it's disio bound then we
should at least be able to get better
than linear
parallelization because all those disio
operations should be
parallelizable beyond the number of
cores that should be based on your hard
drives read
speed yeah so you can see here right
this looks like even though we only have
24 cores gotten to over a th steps per
second
I think you might be right about it not
closing
experiments not be
possible okay so this does not have
clean
termination well we'll just Benchmark
end to end in that
case we'll just do our end to end
benchmarks
workers now we're going to run the RL
training and uh we're going to
use some varied numbers of environments
in could also be an issue where python
spawns a Java process you all your
course yeah I don't know but like I have
very little control here over that stuff
and if we go to
triple triple
redundancy which is
at
1.64 usually triple redundancy gives you
a little bit better
1 dropping number of workers
uh that should make it slower I would
imagine ly yeah we have eight fast pores
let's
see because it's still going to spawn
this number of java processes regardless
it has to spawn a Java process per
D this might actually be a real error
that I can debug
why is it creating so many host it's
creating one for every environment
that's how dvg works I can't do anything
about that
here ah but I see why where this issue
comes from
here this let me see if this gives us
the
error yeah so this is the API usage ER I
commented
uh I want to try your eight worker thing
let's try 24 it should work I imagine
this is going to be way
slower the thing is it's kind of okay if
it makes this many hosts because like
that should parallelize very
well yeah you can see that this is
almost 3x lower linky
48 not 4
there8 48
synchronous I think this is what we
often use for Atari right
on thany 32 is not divisible by three if
you have 96 environments and 24
workers then um that doesn't
work because you have three environments
per core
like that literally doesn't work though
because you have three you have three
environments per
core but
like there are 96 environments total
split across 24 workers three
environments per worker so there's no
integer number of workers that you
collect data from to make a
2K I'll try your thing but I don't think
it works I think we're going to get an
API assert
work why the heck does that work that's
sketchy did I do my math wrong let me
check
huh oh I'm dumb okay yeah yeah yeah
you're right I'm dumb it's not eight
though it's four isn't it four m per
okay yeah you're right I did the math
wrong that does
work all right so we'll use this that
actually looks to be that looks to be
quite nice performance so well done on
that
a NRL comparison or something
we do like a clean RL comparison
sweeps and
autotunes
3X yeah 3X makes sense because 2x is
double buffered but 3x x uh if you have
3x then if they're slow environments you
always get the best ones now it does
change it can change a little bit like
if you have environments that have
really big observations that will change
stuff because that's when you want to
start using zero
copy but that's usually for faster Ms or
Ms that have really big
OBS let's just try this on uh on clean
RL real quick
don't need this wrapper
right just need to convert to gymnasium
to be
yeah this is make m is
good then the neural net as
I need to grab the uh the
puffer
compet is
64 7 *
this
quars oh I'm also realizing this is not
Vanilla Clean RL that I'm messing with
here at all like the uh I need to get
Vanilla Clean RL don't I right
and we can grab the rest of the make
function
grab the only thing that we use is the
puffer M finding for convenience we're
not going to use any of our other tools
that is the fairest way to do
it what's this the 512 Dimension uh
agent is this what we do with our
default
yeah 512 okay so we're matching exactly
now now we're matching
think that we need to
do I think this needs to go at the
anymore not
found needs to be
unexpected suppos to to be able to take
a
seat I guess not in
um the older versions
right yeah that's no
weird we'll just do for now we'll do it
here e
number output
has long dimensionality
holy man it's so funny when I try to
Benchmark like puffer against other
things and I forget that it's like it's
not just how much better is puffer it's
that the other things just don't
work always forget
that like cuz now I have to open up this
freaking site package
right have to put a break point here
right and I have to see what's
what
huh
oh yeah okay I know what's wrong here
yeah I think I can even just replace
this entire make end function
it you can see while I'm doing this
right how much more of a difficult time
I'm having even with c RL which is like
the best thing out there uh compared to
puffer
lib because and it's not clean rl's
fault they're relying on these super old
gym
tools they have like no error checking
whatsoever in a million different
holy like there's just straight up no
way to even test
this I guess I have to use old gym
support right like
okay try this
instead I can't get an end to end
performance
red and
what I'm doing here is I'm just getting
random action data for
testing but you can literally like you
can see what a pain this
and
turn
first why is it working before not
working
now
where G ecosystem like the
reason that uh RL is not where it should
be
what am I doing differently
here importing gem
I well this is just dumb
here
249 we're going to launch this test I'm
going to use the restroom and
hopefully we'll get something by the
time I'm back right
that
this oh this zero copy true is probably
a probably wrong
right we can probably get this running
even faster
you go above num cores there's get way
slower okay so 700 is the best we could
get them
we'll do a up time we'll do steps in 1
minute
106k
so we need to sweep some stuff don't we
let's also see if we can get rewards for
this
you can see like with puffer it took me
a couple hours here to like get a very
obscure old
project
working now we're going to add episode
stats to it just like this
taking ML and DL super
excited
enjoy make sure you do some projects as
well the course material will get
dry a lot of stuff you can do if you get
out there and you know just start on
stuff
try doing this project in
romc AMD and
thinking yeah you don't you're not going
to have a fun time in deep learning with
Nvidia
GPU it's uh it's not a fun
time I mean with uh with AMD gpus yeah
it's all
days they're still kind of
pricey 307s are pretty are pretty now
aren't they
that's
not CPUs be
expensive total reward this
is yeah this is totally wrong
I don't even know how it does
that appears to leak
memory I think this is like a nice
enough little piece of
progress report in
I guess we go now to the uh back to the
MOBA project
um this was an interesting little shot
at
stuff I mean this is about what I
expected that Puffer makes it faster but
uh it's like I can't work magic right
not completely m is going to be really
slow and Jank then uh only so
much I can do there oh but yeah we
should definitely do some stuff on this
okay
I think we're going to move on to the uh
the Moa
here I commit
going to train on the pure C version of
the
environment and we're just going to
train this
check out the want to be for this as
well
how you lost on these pams is very
Jank but uh I mean we can see the stats
of the environment
one damage numbers are going
up kill usage numbers are going
up only going to take six minutes to
train 100 million
steps
100K me see if I can find a couple of
the guys from the Discord
see where they're at because uh they
have environments that like to know
where they are
Nathan posted this like environment in
the
Discord uh a few days ago and I have no
idea what it is
oh linky sent me a
thing a Pokemon run to look at so I got
some little analysis to do while I
wait
okay so I assume that you guys can read
the uh the reward curves
right bosses
art is it also an environment I couldn't
tell says highway on it I thought it
might be like some type of SIM
tackling Highway
M oh are you is this like a a
reimplementation of Highway
en cuz if so that original environment
is so stupidly slow that would actually
be very
useful if you've got code to link for
whichever by the way I'm very much down
to help you get this stuff you know onto
uh online demos with live policies
playing I gotta figure out how to add
HTML to uh the individual pages but the
idea is going to be like We'll add like
either a banner at the top or somewhere
that'll be like you know environment
contributed by so and so it'll have you
know contributor credit right there on
the page I could also put it in the
title here but then if people link the
environment directly they wouldn't see
it
you finish the python once sure no
worries I'm around to help so I'm
definitely around to
help let me look for this let me look at
this run real quick for l
hey linky I don't see this exploding
anywhere this does not look like policy
collapse to
me at least there's no like rapid policy
collapse at the
end like based on the Lost metrics this
is not like a numerical exploding
anything
I'm pretty sure if you just fix the uh
the scripts or whatever for that portion
where it's getting stuck you'll be
good I mean it's like what I'm doing is
very basic right I'm just looking for
any insane spikes in these functions and
there aren't any towards the end so
you're good like you actually have one
over here that's very suspicious but
like the fact that it recovers from this
mean that you're fine
uh okay well this is awkward for some
reason dire is winning every
game
there's they're both leveling but for
whatever reason dire always wins
you can see the reward curves for
these this one is meant to be zero we've
zeroed this one out
intentionally and then death reward is
fine reward overall looks good uh
they're not Spike on Tower reward is
awkward
I don't know they could just be farming
or
something it's almost done you have m's
with action masks um no we do not at the
moment
I've I'm not sure if we need them to be
frank with
you like yes they can
help but um they also add quite a bit of
overhead and complexity to stuff
and the main thing that's obnoxious
about action masks is that they're not
supported by like the gym gymnasium apis
so it's like an API breaking change as
well that's the that's the main
difficulty like the main reason that we
don't have that is because I'd have to
I'd have to further break compatibility
with gy and gymnasium and stuff I don't
think that you should need them uh for
the stuff that you're working on so
much I see what you're probably thinking
though you're thinking about like the uh
you're probably thinking about like
attack range and stuff
for uh for your Tactical
Sim I think if you just represent the
observations reasonably enough it should
be able to figure that
out I can help you with architecture
stuff there are architectural ways to
ensure that it'll uh it'll be able to
get the right it'll be able to function
correctly rather I wouldn't worry too
much about that
also a lot of things just become solved
problems when you TR super fast because
like it's really just like a startup
problem for big action spaces like that
it kind of
disappears over
time well this thing is
done so uh maybe we have an interesting
policy here
policy is supposed to save a
policy how do you handle illegal actions
then ignore them yeah in the environment
itself if you try to do something that's
illegal you just ignore the
action and actually I was I had an idea
just yesterday for a little bit of a
better way of handling it I'm thinking
that probably you should add like one
variable to the observations space that
is uh whether your previous action was
valid or not you know how like games
like if you try to click something
invalid you'll usually get some sort of
visual or audio feedback that you can't
do that just having that one OBS will
probably make it really easy for RL
agents to learn uh you know to learn
invalid action masking on their
own so whatever I did yesterday
apparently broke um broke model
uploading which is really
bad I can still get this model for this
end but we're going to have to fix
that oh maybe
not maybe just it's waiting for
ELO yeah maybe it's just waiting for ELO
yeah yeah it's totally just waiting for
ELO
right I'll wait for
that and we'll uh we'll copy this policy
over and we'll actually be able to see
what the heck is going on with our
agents I'm very excited to get some of
these M online though
I'm considering just porting your uh
your and Noah's environments to see so
that we can have them online ASAP I can
probably do that pretty
soon I asked GPT 4 to Port um Team Rider
and it just refused to do it so I think
uh
I think we're safe on our ultra high
perf
Dev I think that we're doing uh things
that are going to be difficult to
automate for quite a
while
artifact yeah
while everything that I'm deing one
right at the moment is free and open
source software got docs on puffer ai.
github.io got demos on puffer Dogg and
also the code is available right here
I'll paste this link in the uh in the
chat if you want to help me out a ton
for free start the
repository All I Ask helps me a ton I've
also uh I post about all this stuff on
Twitter as well which is jarez 53
follow stuff there if you want more RL
news finally some M people know how to
play well I figured that the Moa like
there are enough people that know how to
play like League or DOTA
is the it's the yellow one made it like
the most obnoxious color
doing don't look very
smart but here come three of the agents
that have learned how to do stuff
yet why did these guys guys not do
anything is my
question like to train us like a
reasonable policy
I think that maybe if I if I modify the
way the ELO is
it well the other big issue at the
moment is
uh this thing crashes
in between
runs see if I can figure out why this
thing crashes in between
it I like this site you got to add more
stuff to
I think the biggest
problem well there's a big problem with
ELO but the biggest problem is the thing
crashing
yeah I'm trying to think why this thing
would
not I ran a sweep yesterday and it
didn't
pi what's the
envin is it just the rendering that's in
P
python the enin syon orc
it's not that hard to Port either way
I'm not telling you you have to do it
but I'm offering to help you with it if
you want it online
oh test stop pie yeah you're linking
stuff and it's not letting
you post in
Discord I'll grab it from the
e oh wait you can build when you say you
can build the C with clang is the
environment in C link code
man run in
Python rendering in the seile yeah I can
show you how to do that stuff I just got
to see your code set up e
I see you're typing it in
Discord I'll pull that up on stream if
that's all
right we'll we'll take a look at
it one of the perks of contributing to
Puffer
tactical Pi tactical pix tactical H same
structure as your
MOA oh you already did that's cool that
you did this in
see yeah I see I see the Discord no
worries if the code's not in the private
repo I'll just look at it and fix it for
you man
you this
is it's not broken I don't know how to
compile it
oh uh yeah no problem so did you see
like the build local Dosh script in the
Moa so there's a build script to run in
pure C and if you want to run in Python
while rendering in the C
file what you do with that you have to
add to the setup.py
I got
here I had to fight with this for a
while as well what you do is you pass
the path to the
pass the path to the module like dooba
or whatever and then the source file you
put the
Pix put rib in the
includers and then you also have to pass
uh the platform flag sometimes you're
using
you're just you're having Linker errors
is
all if that works we can put a we can
put like a buildup of that online like
immediately I can help you I will
absolutely help you as well if you have
like basic Nets and stuff I can get you
networks training I can get you networks
ported into direct to see with puffer
N.H many things can be done
here but I am eager to like perf test
this environment and like see if I can
help you with ob spaces because I just I
want to make sure that like you're
whatever you're doing with the OB spaces
it's not going to be impossible to train
on you know I know like all the common
pitfalls
need to change okay you need to change
the asset so you don't get sued yep okay
yeah do that first and then let's
go but yeah like just pick a day next
week if you want that you'll be around
and I will like I'll gladly just will do
that on stream I'll just help you get
everything working with it
and I'll show you a bunch of the RL side
of things as well since you know I know
that's some of what you want to get out
of doing
website I mean you can put it on yours
if you want if you want to have it on
yours and have me link to it that's fine
you can also like embed uh you know you
know like you can embed your author
information I I like I don't care
whatever you want to do I'm assuming you
want to open source
stuff if not then that's a different
story
right oh about getting sued ah I see
okay uh yeah it's got to be
the yeah the assets have got to swap no
that's fine okay yeah I thought we were
going to have like an open sourcing
thing okay but we're good there yeah
yeah it's just the assets and just swap
I if you swap the character assets will
be Fine Man game mechanics are not
patentable like if you're using
character or spell animations or [ __ ]
like that yeah but I think if you're
just using piles like we'll swap those
eventually but nobody will care for time
being
screen like this is uh this is working
I'm kind of confused
yeah this works now I don't know what
was wrong before
uh I also kind of want to grab kung's
carbs fix while I'm at
it
that thank Kung for
his contribution right here e
good welcome YouTube
folks we are
currently about to run a big hyper
parameter
sweep this
environment um I'm going just launch
this for now I
think yeah I'm going to launch this for
now
we're going to see what this does and
then I'm going to work on improving the
ELO Cals in the
meantime I'll give a brief overview of
what I'm
doing I
see
so we have this game on puff. if you
want to play
it like a mini version of League of
Legends or DotA can see I've got
characters they've got abilities right
this is like the assassin class so it
has like the dash strike thing speed
Buffs and so on other characters as well
bursty character so lower but he can go
up got like this big AOE
stun big this big stun and he's got
burst damage and all
that uh so what we're trying to do is
train some good neural networks to play
this
quite
tricky and I think that the main thing
that we are missing at the
moment is the ELO calculations are not
great and need to go figure out why that
is
random see how we're calling
this
elos C
ELO
function
is
here we do call
This And
I think the main issue is that when I
calculate ELO you're always playing for
radiant and your opponent is always
playing for
dire if you think about it right like
you only have to be good at playing one
side uh in order to be high on the ELO
table so yeah like if I think about it
right okay I think I see what's
happening so let's say that you're
always learning how to play radiant
right uh so then you learn to play
radiant you get evaluated you score High
ELO because you're beating the opponent
when you're playing
radiant but then you go into the
opponent pool and then when I train a
new policy and evaluate it against
it now the opponent that is High ELO is
taking on the dire side but it doesn't
know how to play that side it only knows
how to play for radiant so the fix for
this I have to change the indexing
around a little bit um which is somewhat
fortunate
but I think we should
be
okay just have to figure out how to
change this
indices let's change this from my
indices to be radiant indices and then
this is going to be dire
then yeah
so this gets to be a little different
now because all this stuff is going to
get
into the
iteration because what we have to do now
is we have actually have to select some
games that you play for dire some games
you play for
radiant so for range num
opponents
radiant
Els like
this
then have opponent obs
what's happening here oh we don't need
this anymore
right we do need
opponent need to know is our opponent
the policy
actions uh and I think we actually do
need to
allocate to pre-allocate a tensor here
don't
we kind of
rough yeah we need to pre-allocate a
tensor here
essentially I'm trying to make like a
really nice ELO Cal thing and uh it's a
little bit tricky to do
that because of there's a bunch of like
tensor indexing
now and now I need to figure out the
action tensor
zeros num
M's uh
10 times num M's right
times we want numm
10 Len
action
SP
do
work then
have license dis
well this should now be the same shape I
believe
so I think I can just set actions
correctly
perfectly thanks for saving me an
hour it took me more than an hour to
figure that out so maybe you're quicker
at it than I
go I mean hey send it man I'm uh I'm
ready to help you on that side whenever
you
want I'd love to have like even an early
version of that MV online that we can
like play around with not everything on
the site needs to be done we can label
stuff work in progress I just want to
like start getting things online
because here's here's the thing I'm
trying to figure out right now
Nathan like you notice that there's at
least the way I see it right now
everything that is in C Is Awesome
everything that is in Python is awesome
all the stuff in the middle is a God
awful mess so I'm hoping that once we
get like three or four M's written up in
this format we're going to be able to
see some common patterns and figure out
like a better way to save this for being
so painful so then puffer just becomes
this awesome place where we have
everything set up so it's so so easy to
just like push code from python to scon
to C and like have everything be fast
and have everything be nice and
compatible right that's the
yeah will clean up and
push awesome link the repo somewhere I
don't even know where all the any of
this code is man I'd love to just like
go through it and see how you're writing
stuff and see if I have any ideas for
you
obviously got to swap the uh the
character model
assets where's uh I haven't seen like
South in the in the chat
lately I hope he's still around
somewhere wanted to see more of that
art I really like some of the things
he's put together like even this like
silly puffer which is like I don't even
know what to do with it but it's like so
funny to
me like this animation is just so silly
I like
animations puffer emote
yeah I think that we can probably like
export it as an emote or something I'd
like to be able to use it more broadly
though
St an asset
folder yeah I think that we can probably
do something like that we need to clean
them up and put them on a Sprite sheet
but then yes the difficult thing at the
moment right is like I only have the
static ones South was working on
animations but I haven't seen him for
the last
week I'm hoping he just went on vacation
and see him again in here
destination long
first long for course
something
see and what can we do in the meantime
Happening
Here stream has actually gotten some uh
some view on on X today which is
cool I see a lot of this like obnoxious
I mean car paath is great um but i' like
I've seen like he's quote quoting
somebody right like there are a lot of
these obnoxious AGI definitions and
shenanigans uh if you want to be mildly
entertained at the very least and read
like a portion of satire not
satire this is a fun little
article
copy the fun
article quick
read why is this not uh finishing games
is the question I have
OBS M's some
games
opponents in
games seems like this should
work oh there it
is it
ELO we figure out file loading and see
uh we found a
hack let me find it for you
so what you do is you leave your C code
alone your C code is very nice
right and then what you do is this it's
kind of
gross but just set uh th dir to the
absolute path using python functions
from within
scon uh when you init the renderer only
when you init the renderer and then that
will let you load all the assets and
then you can see H dir back so you don't
mess up any of your paths that's like a
non-destructive and really easy work
around for
now this is in the uh this should be on
GitHub as
well I also this like this if render is
no logic is very important because you
don't want to like you don't want to
make the renderer unless you actually
call render
okay cool yeah do that for
now um I think I need to run this again
don't
that's only if I'm well where are you
loading files that aren't in the
renderer you can do the exact same thing
when you init the environment if
you for smaller pieces of dat like for
small pieces of data though I think it
is legitimately smarter just to embed
them in the file because then like
nothing can ever go wrong with file
structure and
such I don't know what other data you
would be needing
though I also what I did for um the
pathing in order to make pathing fast I
changed it from pre computation to
caching so the way it works now is like
whenever you try to path to a location
that doesn't have uh a predefined
optimal path it'll do the computation
and since that whole logic takes like 2
seconds that means that you're going to
do at most two seconds worth of work
during the entire training run to
allocate uh the pre-computed pathing but
you don't have the startup time and then
on web as well uh you don't have any
overhead for that on web like having to
load 250 Megs it's pretty
nice have to be a little smart with
things right
just the
map oh let me show you how to do the
map there's a cleaner way than directly
pasting it
in this is my game
m.h this is like a bunch of data right I
generate this from
Python and uh I just hash include it
hash include this you don't have it in
your main source
file at the top it's pretty clean it's
pretty
easy that hash include will never mess
up
relative to the current
file it's that's always going to be in
the path
okay this indexing logic is not quite
correct but uh I'm going to wait a
second to fix this I check the
check
this broken
pipe why is it broken
pipe how long did it take to
break the break after one run like
before
m.h yeah I'm hash including the game
appap like this and technically what I'm
probably going to do is I'm going to
take all this stuff and I'm just going
to put this in like game data. H or
something that's pretty clean you have a
separate data file but it's just a Doh
you it
directly and you don't have to deal with
like C file reading and
errors maybe it's
uh maybe I can actually get a reasonable
eror
message 27
and
pong oh sweet
already hang
cython so I can help you this has got
before this goes online this has got to
get to see I can help with that
y it's from a month
ago
what what do you mean already
it's yeah no I meant like I I thought
that you were saying that you ported it
to see like just now
scon yeah but I'm confused because
you're saying just enough to get it
online but
don't has to go to C to get online
doesn't
it I'm confused
you didn't find a way to like to run
scon online did
you I mean this is easy enough to
Port doing tactical okay yeah sure I can
Port this I mean I'll get bored one of
these evenings and I'll probably just
Port it for you to uh to see because
this is super easy to do yeah this is
like trivial
I'll have to do the rendering Port well
but that's I mean it's pong it's
do
puffer do puffer
I mean you linked me the GitHub right I
was just going to look at
it there's not anything in here as far
as I can tell
yet unless you're prototyping in
I'll help you support this to see a star
is a little bit of a
pain buffer
leaks leaks on open source code
on oh jeez the iso render yeah I forgot
that's kind of hard isn't
it and this is going to be so much
faster not going to have to worry about
a lot of the station
co I wonder if this is actually how they
do their pathing
do very cool though and you do like text
file Maps
yep
Co very nice
I'm trying to think what this thing is
failing on and uh how I can get and I
guess for now right I can just do
um I just change this to like
three I should get an error message at
least
now black
all the
different also there's a speed Benchmark
for me to run on GPU Drive
and then one other thing I want to do on
side
here
get Glen lost of things to
major all right we're good for the next
little bit here then guys to uh fix up
this low cal thing
see if we can make this really
opponent
[Music]
oh uh yeah this should just
be twice
the number of environments right
in order to get a random
team and we just have to fix our
indexing right
here I will do this in a second I is to
restro real quick um and then we will
fix up ELO Cals we'll make sure that
we're running uh proper ELO Cals we'll
hopefully fix automated experiments
we're very very close to being able to
run like large scale MOA experiments on
be right
here is figure out how to do this
indexing correctly this should massively
improve the quality of our ELO
evaluations uh I could pretty easily
clean this up and make it for arbitrary
two games at the very least and then
we'll go from there
this have
dis
trying to think what's like the clean
way
to index
um I need to figure out like which
observation from radiant and dire are
going to go to which
policies and it's a particularly tricky
and nefarious bit of indexing here
is I don't know why this is so hard like
in my head this just does not not make
sense
um well what I want to do
right I'm thinking about this the wrong
mm's and
two maybe I just need to get this to be
maybe I have like a a just awkward
number of Dimensions
here for new ml folks I'm getting used
to tensor operations is like one of the
major early things you got to do in the
field and it it gets easier but it
doesn't tet to
way easiest way is generally to get
around just to just like have small
versions of your multi-dimensional
tensors and then play around with them
Z this is actually good
right because I can
grab environment
zero I can grab like a block of
environments and then I should be able
to
grab uh the
specific indices that I want
yes I think this is good and then I
don't need radiant and dire indices
right I just need team
see if this make
sense freaking five dimensional
tensor I forgot to delete numm it's a 4D
tensor what I'm trying to do here
basically is I'm trying to get the data
into a shape where
everything I want to do is a very simple
slice operation and I don't have a whole
bunch of
Jank okay so now we see that we have
eight blocks n opponents is
eight
yeah I think this is
good then what we do is we do this numpy
random
randint this can just
be this can be Bann this
bot oh way stupid
bot
one I think
so okay because now go like this
right
tce of zero
and we have
uh
assignments
yeah so now we to
assignment now this the tricky tensor
operation
correct
then so hard to think about this
it's going to be like my
OBS
and then this is opponent OBS
OBS and then this is opponent OBS is one minus
is one minus
t okay
I think this works so far so this is
like this is a pretty clean way of doing
the
five yeah so this wrong it's uh
teams indices
uh
teams not
shape no still not this
t. take
maybe welcome YouTube folks we're doing
some complex index indexing order to
build an ELO calculation system for uh
this MOBA reinforcement learn
environment like mini Dota or Le
take
input and
index now this is not what
we take long
dim Take Along
d
five there's definitely a way of doing
this
like along I'm trying to figure out what
I'm trying to figure out right now is
how to
index I have this tensor of ones and
zeros I'm trying to grab this Dimension
here I'm trying to grab it based on the
ones and zeros in here the the output
dimension of this should be 16x
5 deck
here last
jity that this is going to be a waste of
time but we'll see yeah we'll see if the
new base model
is able to do anything at all this
should be a very easy question that I
just haven't had to do in a while
yeah there you
go I forgot about that weird indexing
thing need an index
opponent okay and then we
do my OB
right this should give us the correct
shape
data in by
5 by the OB
shape
correct reape
view
d
m
time
one any
idea I think your comment got cut off
um post the full thing in the Discord
just post the full Trace in the Discord
for me real
quick I'll debug you I'll debug if you
just put it in
okay we actually have the correct
observations
now so we get
to actually get to delete a lot of
garbage this is quite
clean my OBS opponent OBS and now this
is where you have to to break point
again and figure out some
indexing
but oh you put this in the neural MMO
Discord hold
on so I need to know what you're running
this from are you running like the
neural MMO demo scripts if so did you
pip install
it um you're also you're
not wait you're running train.py okay I
assume this is the neural
MMO
yeah I'll help you hold
on
like I assume this the docks one here
right it just tells
you on
baselines trying to
verify yep I got
you run and I'll figure this
out it's possible we have to pin a
version of puffer I think that we'd
already done that but I'll double check
it
we have this pin to
not we have this pin to not
3.11
seriously I don't know when that
happened
work appreciate been stuck for so long
yeah no worries that's what I'm here
for my stuff is not supposed to be hard
to install so if it's taking you a long
time probably there's something wrong
with
it I try very very hard to make stuff
not be a pain
uh it all the new stuff I'm doing is a
lot easier as well but you know we do
have support for
this so this looks like this
belt what did you run this with local
mode true
it there requirement text or something
that I'm
missing I know we have puffer lib
somewhere this don't
telling you to start puffer lip you can
start puffer lip after I fix your
on H there we
go
Vector I'm very surprised that we didn't
have this pinned to something
um I'm very surprised we didn't have
this
pinned
something it's Vector not vectorization
that's why we renamed it in a 1 so I
think that this was made for
you
0.6 might be all the way back at
repository I'm a bit more concerned
doing that one linky there are a couple
other fixes in the main branch that
haven't like I could break
stuff
there bad thing to do on a Friday this
I'm happy to do
no it can't be this like we just never
PR the baselines hold on
didn't think we had it on that that old
that's ridiculous
oh this is a legitimate issue sure
definitely a legitimate issue I'm trying
to figure out like I think it's like
some versioning
thing with Puffer
thought I could have sworn so there was
a 2.1 update that probably messed some
stuff up
okay yeah here 2.1 is not the
latest what's happened
here when you clone
Leb Nur for
semester yeah that should not happen man
like I get so mad when other researchers
do that and I try so hard to prevent
that like at least in this case neural
MMO is a seveny year long project and
it's just like it's gotten to the point
where there's just so much stuff in it
and so much like used in so many
different things that like versions get
screwed up and stuff let me just fix
this for you um I it's probably
something dumb like the code works it's
like there's some versioning
thing but yeah I like more people are
supposed to do this like I'm online
streaming for a reason right and one of
the biggest reasons is to fix stuff next
to going wrong with my software
yeah know there's there's something let
me fix it there's there's some [ __ ]
here I've learned so much like my
defense as well was just like a few
months ago but I I've learned so so so
much as soon as I got out of Academia on
like building High perf software there's
going to beur more neural MMO coming
soon and it's going to blow everything
here out of the water but like in the
meantime this stuff is supposed to work
and like it's it's supposed to be easier
than everything else out there at the
least this is ridiculous that I have it
like this
yep such a simple screw up on my hard as
well I [ __ ] this
up at least that's what it's look we'll
see if it goes any deeper
so you didn't do anything
wrong um this is totally my bad I forgot
to update so we like we fixed a bunch of
stuff and we changed a bunch of
dependencies here try this
Branch just go to the baselines repo now
try 2.1 and try these commands if it
doesn't work let me know and I'll fix it
but this should give you this should
give you everything that you were
looking for before plus like way better
Performance Plus a bunch of miname tasks
that you try stuff out on based on uh
kyung's work so it should give you
everything
basically what happened is 20 was the
version that we were we were actively
maintaining like the main puffer Branch
to be up to date with that
um but then like when the competition
ended right and we did like the
follow-up work on neural MMO we didn't
go and like pin all the correct versions
to make sure that 20 would work we just
made sure everything was clean and
working in
21 and then I forgot to update the
default Branch from 2 to 21 so my bad
sorry sorry about
that in the future if you ever run into
any problems with any of my software
just like jump into chat or Discord or
like one of those places immediately um
I try to provide very good support for
all of my
stuff and if that resolves your issue
please do feed the puff for a star helps
them out a lot buffer Stars
well issue was isolated no no no no no
you just yeah like there are some
authors that are like [ __ ] are going
to like tell you stuff like that that's
not how I roll um if you're having setup
issues like and you're not a straight up
like brand new programmer then either
there's a bug or I have something
unintuitive right
like literally I don't have a way to
improve any of these things if people
don't tell me though right so like
literally like just jump in immediately
and like I I'll either give you a quick
simple answer or um you know I'll have
to fix something like this it's no big
deal I don't know if you've seen any of
my more recent stuff but uh since you're
working in RL now like there's going to
be a lot more cool stuff coming from uh
from my side like this is a Ultra ultra
high performance Moa that is in
development for reinforcement learning
it runs like a million steps per second
per CPU core has all the features of
like know well strip down League of
Legends or DOTA has a bunch of different
characters that you can play sides got
simpler stuff like the snake environment
and there a whole bunch more they're
coming uh to reinforcement learning so
it's going to be a very fun field to
working very
soon I'm on this
it so complicated though de and pretty
rough
what do we have we have uh action shape
like
this
be
five
right basically what I'm trying to do is
I'm trying to figure out how to make
make sure that I set the correct portion
of the
component these are
good then we have action
sh okay so then all we have to do is
actions
of uh a range
so I
mean complicated ass indexing
but no longer need agent a range clean a
couple things up
this is can
be
action I
anymore and the scores need to be
um ores need to be changed as well
oh well we have Team assignments here
right this is
me why this run worked and the other one
didn't not have any errors in here at
none thing
weird
educ time being though we'll just work
on this for a bit
some ways I'm quite happy about the uh
the open AI release today yeah you're
using RL for language models but
like mean I like I was doing all this
stuff based on the idea that I think
that you're going to need RL for
long-term progress in AI to continue and
that seems to have been proven
today chipping away on this type this
area of it
it's a bit concerning how long that this
takes though um well I guess I this is
on my
local lower
GPU
um oh I guess it must have timed out
right yeah it must have timed
out see oh yeah of course it timed out
it's not going to win any games cuz the
models suck
right yeah
try
this now maybe it won't take forever it
should have a model that actually wins
the game so it wasn't being slow it's
literally just the models were too dumb
to win the
I'm surprised I'm not
seeing game
paths oh yeah cuz that's going to be
your
yeah makes sense
why I don't know why it's not winning
games need like a good model to try out
against it I guess
something is weird
here oh it could also be that the
indexing is wrong
that would cause this as
well
right yeah that would totally cause
this looks like I do have some debugging
to trying to think what it would be that
um messed up the ELO
we this one here has three
experiments I think they're all good
experiments
right all three are good experiments I
don't know why the ELO is this High
that's
here right so no games were won um
meaning that I have to go through now
and check the indexing more
carefully CU that yeah the model that I
use should definitely win something
right
just you just put the I think that this
is a good
model I'm going to put this one there
for um
wrong observation of
indices range and I should just look at
what these indices are make sure that I
have a reasonable set of indices
here not getting anywhere right
z
one SKS 10 indices
zero
yeah those indices actually look good to
me
and you can see
here get
the corresponding set of indices
right these observation indices look
these actions look correct right and
then we do
on
N time num
M something is very wrong here
not put a break point
here want to see what our actions look
like before they go into the
having some dependency
issues yeah Post in
did you pip install pip install Dash e
dot the baselines
repo the new baselines has a setup it
has a p project. toml in it so the
baselines repo has the extra
dependencies try that
leaved I'll be back in a minute I'm just
going to restro and uh I'm going to fix
this I'll fix your stuff if there's
still an issue go for from
catch and have bugs in your tempers now
can
action and we can see now that these are
correctly laid
out like uh now the only thing that we
need to know is team assignment
whether this actually fixes it or not we
will see
new
error check the uh check the
GitHub the instructions were updated for
the new version have new docs to look
at
here right here my guy
on I and num M's
AP did actually win a
game well well did It win a
game yeah it did it did a game was one
that means the actions are
good
Dow I'm pretty happy with this as a
result
okay got a me problem torch not compiled
with C
enabled one much better yeah that should
help
uh you can technically use puffer tank
if you just want like a Docker that has
Cuda working you'll have to check out uh
you know the correct version of puffer
libon there cuz it uses the most
upto-date version but that comes with
that might have a a to new of a torch
version though come to think of it h
you're probably easier to do your own
local set up and not mess with our
Dockers
this went fairly well though
here should be a
substantially nicer update
can't wait to show up to
class amaz
them that's cool hey I for your team it
turns out you can literally just like
open stream and chat with the guy who
made it so that's a pretty an easy hack
isn't it
so much more is coming to uh to RL
including like neural MMOs esque
environments over the next few months
it's just so much code for me to write
the next uh the next update to puffer
lib to give you an idea is going to
include like probably between 5 and
7,000 lines of uh simulation code in PC
for like a ton of different
environments which is bigger than the
whole of puffer put together and I think
it's actually going to be close to
bigger than neural MMO like neural MMO
that okay got that done now all we have
to to do is figure out
526 all I have to do is figure
out why these sweeps are
failing it seems to have something to do
with multiprocessing come to think of
I mean
it's I'm going to just you know what I'm
going to just for
now literally be done right now if I do
this and I can do other cool things on
stream for the rest of the stream I do
this this
way that
I doubt Nathan is still around right
you're not here Nathan still
right 3D might just be lurking and
co-working I doubt it
run going to run with I believe the
latest carbs update right
okay I'm going to go over the plan for
the rest of the day
here um I have I don't know something is
screwy with multiprocessing probably
some weird thing with Ray or whatever I
don't know
but I've gotten this into a good State I
got the stuff done I needed to get done
I got a version of it working with
sweeps I have it looks stable as well I
got the carbs update applied and I got
the ELO patch update applied so now this
just has to run some
experiments um we've done all the hard
work for today I get to have a little
bit of fun so I'm going to decide
whether I want to like Port pong to
Native sea
or what I want to do I'm going to do
something cool uh and it's going to be
pretty fastpaced for the next say 2 and
a half hours till like 7:30 and then
I'll get dinner but uh in order to do
that I do need to
grab I need to grab a quick snack I
think I have stuff for a shake I'm going
to take a couple quick minutes and go
sort that out so I actually have a bit
of energy to do this and then uh we'll
go from there be right
back
kind of liking the idea of just porting
pong to
while also make sure that our sweep is
failing
you know the other thing I was thinking
about was whether we want to have these
environments be natively vectorized in C
it and I think that we can do con
vectorize and see without having to
quite deal with that much difficulty
like mine is a mess where's all the cool
research everybody's just going crazy
over freaking 01
this is not actually
correct right
here don't set frame skip to wanted eval
this OB stuff is not bad some of these
should be like should
Beed don't do it multiple
times it really doesn't make too much of
a difference
used yeah there are too many arrays
being used where they don't need to be
I actually don't know how this works
looking at this
I actually don't know if this is correct
looking at it I don't know if that's how
the actual paddle AI usually works
well since Nathan isn't
here what do you say that we
um we surprised him by ping his
environment to see and compiling it for
web
hours see how much gas I've got left in
the tank I think I can probably do
it make sure that um our experiment is
not crashing for though because that's
top priority
on oh yeah we're
good good
lib
M
ation eight
Dimension logging yeah that's pretty
much
the
terminals
void my
kind of cool that like there's enough um
C code in this repository that this
literally just knows how to Port it in
my exact style
already uh yeah we want it
toct then
done here
right
pick stuff
here yeah this is we don't have to think
very hard about this like this will just
Auto Port we'll have to think afterwards
um because there going to be a few
changes I'm going to make
observation so we just had to give it
the little
hint
fine and we
you can see I'm um I've been very
critical of language models no on social
media and
such you can see how I'm using it I'm
using it for very very brain dead things
only
in that what it
was unsigned in
up
here name to me
we're going to make like a clip function
and stuff to simplify this after we're
just doing the naive Port
first but if you can see the difference
between um this code and the C code
not any harder to have this BNC right in
fact it's easier because when I go to
debug this the compile time is shorter
and I have additional tools
all
correct just checked
it uh this is a mistake right
here
see this is this should be reset
this is reset
round but almost almost just caused a
bug but I was
watching language models right
wall and reset reset round you can see
now it did it correctly because we gave
it the correct version at the
top
we're still missing some
functions so we did this in
net
um but now the thing is you see all
these things that passed
in all these pointers up
top uh we don't necessarily want all to
beers so what I do is I have this nit
function I also make an allocate
at and then this is going to not take in
looat St this is only going to take
in uh the things that we actually care
about which are
here minus this logging I don't know
why these are all
constants this is going to go to the
allocate
and what we're going to
do is we're going to just start
allocating
observation there it goes allocates it
for
us now we have all these things
allocated we have this inet
I really don't like the boiler plate
associated with this but I haven't found
a better way yet to have um a version of
the code that lets you pass in the
memory versus take stuff out we can
simplify this after but there is going
to be some
free is
going free only has to
free one allocation which environment
this this one does need
it it has a lot of
stuff and then we get rid of this
garbage
uh and now start porting the rendering
code
because python has the
here do is we're going to
here and this is a very short little
class this should be very easy to long
after all
Tru what on Earth how does it have that
much stuff
stuff and even know why it did uh so
width height paddle width paddle height
ball width ball
height literally doesn't need any of
this
plant I've got to figure out a
standardized naming Syntax for
Stuff uh
this uh there are a couple errors I can
see in the port right already
right
the
um now I have to do the init
right here and we just
window don't need Dot and code anymore
this python
thing
do
void we do need a free client
right close
client because you need to call
close and now we do from
client probably needs to be typed death
client right type
death
Cent yeah that's
good now for render we
do
zero in
drawing got puff background what the
heck puff
background now we had puff background
render
from oh he got
render yeah literally super Maven knows
already I always use the same background
left this is a
w angle paddle
left what we're doing here these are the
bounds for the um these are the bounds
for the
this rectangle okay so the ball is a
rectangle why is rectangle
hell what
map ble
left that
is that is
something
holy um
go check the API for RB real
quick I think it it actually gets easier
and
see oh I also I get to take the filter
off don't
I my audio quality a little
bit there
dra a
rectangle yeah so because we're now
using the um the C API this actually
gets easier which is quite
funny so we just draw a left
paddle and then we just do
draw
rectangle like
this and and this should not be be
client P left
color and then we do draw right paddle
ball
text
okay for
all right and now I need to
do this is going to
be uh client width divide by
[Music]
two 1030
and what is Puff text
here uh puff
text he did something with
funny I forgot that I had
this that's kind of nice of him that he
matched the uh the look and
feel text and then this one should
now yeah this is going to match it right
drawing there we go so we added an extra
100 lines we got the client to Native
c um now we probably need the
binding but we don't need the binding
just yet we should be able to
this would be a better match right oops
snake.
H now I got to grab all of his python
side code to use for
params
40 paddle with it's going to be
20 in fact we can probably just to speed
this up
right I just
like that
paste in
um battle
ball withd now
copy ball
WID
Speed Max
score
[Music]
21 s data
now we you see
my long star n you want to go grab the
signature from
pong.
here
right like to grab the
oops grab the signature
allocate because from cide you use the
allocate method not the init method so
it gets a little easier
xcore yeah so this is good now we have
the environment allocated right
we don't need any of this
stuff uh and we can just refer to the
way that I implemented this
nen then we just do I guess I called it
renderer that's better than client
we'll leave it client for now because I
don't want to [ __ ] with
it
client
we don't we're not going to do
client we don't we're not going to do the MLP stuff just
yet what we are going to do though is
we're going to
do we're going to do reset
M and while window not window should
close
where's the
actions where's the
why is it and actions of oh I guess it's
like this maybe kind of
guess we do Step
n
vender
n okay and now we do close
client uh
preallocated return zero
now all we have to do
is snake uh build
local goes
here and then we do need
here I should technically just be able
to sing
yeah there we
go
so I have a SIM link to RB
Here
Local we use the clang
one long game
long.
C and now this is where we go into debug
mode and you see how easy this
grab long
game. C and the thing that I forgot
that's in here there are a couple extra
flags that make this a little easier
we don't need it here though what we do
is I limit it to three
errors and now I have just uh you know a
few errors on this side and I can very
very quickly
debug so here for instance this is a
type depth struct see am I this struct
defined load is not
equals so this should be
a this needs to be a float
star because otherwise we can't assign
to this right yeah we can't assign to
this so this is a
mistake in the the design of this
actions and then this is going to be a
float star Rewards
we'll change uh several aspects of this
design as
well unkn name color
hash include
[Music]
329 effed
expression yeah these types I don't know
why I left the types on I because I just
copy paste from the
unused uh yeah because we don't need
these these get
Library
lib long
game and we get a seg fult but we have a
dress sanitizer
on
so
well can we first of all this should be
C I don't think that changes anything oh
that does change
everything there we
it why does it go this fast and why
can't I control the paddle
30 I think it's like 15 or something
right skip
four this is still crazy fast oh yeah
yeah we didn't
recompile well it looks like the paddles
are in the wrong spot right
were they being
rendered yeah so these are being
rendered in the wrong spot
yes let's see what happens
now
oops
no
paddles this is just paddle
whoops see what the actions are supposed
to
be I didn't really check what the how
the actions work when I uh i p
thats oh I don't know why there are two
actions
then yeah so we this is the logic we
need
see this
the
zero is equal
to
down oh
you can actually technically make it
even a little easier
right zero this is going to be up this
is two and then we would just do N
Action Z 0 like
easy okay so
so here we
go I can control
it and I can play Pawn
beatable it doesn't seem to take your
velocity into account
I got ask Nathan if he checked the uh
the actual way that the game is
implemented I have not been able to
score single point on this thing so I'm
questioning whether the uh the game is
possible or if I'm just
there is it is pong reliant on like an
acceleration that isn't implemented here
in order to actually be winable that a
acceleration oh there it is I got a
point okay it's just
hard very hard without frame skip as
well I mean with frame skip
how long did that take a little less
than an
hour for the initial port
yet uh I guess we should make the python
binding
right yeah we should make the python
binding I also don't know why you're
controlling the paddle on the right
that's kind of
weird no wait is that how it
works maybe you do control the paddle on
the right in Atari Pong
yeah wait you totally do what am I
talking
about
okay
pix oh this is going to Output a PA
C is the
problem pong
this
okay don't need any of this garbage
what we do need to look at are the way
that we
Implement yeah we do need the game
though don't
we so we'll do c death
struct um
environment my C
yeah we need this what we need is this
definition
so we just take this struck definition
and uh this is the wrapper to expose the
environment to
need stru
entity or was it
[Music]
client
Cent there should be some other stuff
probably have to
do class
environment all the stuff that this
[Music]
needs in order to expose this
m
equals yeah this needs to be
substantially more actually there's uh
the signature is going to be annoying
for
this but this is partially why I'm doing
this is in order to figure out how to
make this less annoying in the future
right because what happens is we end up
having to do stuff like this like for
this init function here I need to
pass uh this is going to be I think it's
numpy
it's going to be like I know it's going
to end up being something float
star
data hopefully that did it
right uh and then this is
actually signed star
data okay and then we have to change the
signatures
here to be CNP ND
CNP okay and let's see what what this
does and we get this
one uh this did a decent job I think
oops initial ball Speed Max ball
speed do like
this and sure let's why
not
so this goes
away this client is actually not going
to
stay like this
um we're going to
do this is going to be
CNP this is going to be client star
client then this is going to
be
with yeah we need all these
things we just
do s dot
with so now the
client the client is going to go under
render
en and this is going to
be
turn well it doesn't have to return
anything because it's shared buffers
step render close now the only thing we
have to do
is these things can
go okay these things go here uh these
things get tabbed over
one and now what we have to do
is self. client
this let me make sure I'm doing this the
way I think I
am equal equal
null okay so it's if client is
null that's when we make the client
this and then we just do if client is
not equal null close the client and then
we null it and we free all we do not do
free
allocated we simply do
free uh self.
n and I'm sure we have to import that uh
we also need some
prototypes so should
be see my pong
allocate garbage prototype here and then
this is going to
be client make
client yeah all these
things you can see there's a lot of
garbage boiler plate which is one of the
things we're working to get rid of um
but we need some examples in order to be
able to do
that then we get rid of all this stuff
cuz we don't need it
100 line binding file could be
onp we copy this
file and then we
do uh set
and now this is going to be with
equals so all these variables are just
going to get set
here
Ms agent render mode
with uh this does need to be defined
like
so
spaces render mode is human we don't
need to care about these
see my pong that's
good step doesn't matter we no longer
have to do any of
this we just do
four
CM
render then we do not need the rayb
client or any of this stuff anymore
don't need the render test we'll leave
the perf test in there um though we're
not going to use it right
so there's like three times more code
here than there should be but we will
work on that portion uh
afterwards
enironment we just
okay and now we need
config
[Music]
ocean pong what we need to do let's just
do copy config
ocean config ocean pong that
any ocean pong we'll just strip a lot of
this stuff
out we'll just get rid of all of this
stuff because who needs it
yeah don't need any of this
stuff honestly yeah we really don't need
any of this
stuff package is Ocean and the name
is
my long I
python so and then we also have to edit
the setup
obnoxious this needs to get copied so
you see why I'm doing this is
essentially it's not just cuz we we want
pong as an N which is nice on its own uh
we also want to have like the okay this
is how much duplicated code there
is and like maybe there's some
opportunities to
be S pong
import pong we don't step
all need render
Here s pong oh right
here building in the wrong spot
perfect now we
have now we've got our
issues how the heck did I mix tabs and
spaces
free I think it needs this free
right cannot convert close
client s.
client to a python object does it need
the full freaking definition of
this oh no no no hold on Moa
you need to import these from extern
it's CDE from
exter CDE from Stern
pong. and then yeah so these things are
all nested okay so these things get
nested right
def C type Dev I think there's one at
the bottom here C type Dev
yeah it's
C
okay see type def struct client like
this C type def not allowed
should
be see type dep struct
reward this is inside of the extern
right see def oh it's extern
from
okay uh apparently some errors right
have according to this Lots they're
probably all the same
[Music]
pong yeah so this [ __ ] here needs to
be here this needs to go
here like
this that's the
issue and that's is that fewer errors
than before I can't
tell self. width and not ass
um float oh these are all
floats okay
cool
float I don't know why they're all
floats but they're floats cool
it
h yeah this is the signature that you
[Music]
want this
okay you can see the actual signature
that it takes
there don't know why this is so
awkward really shouldn't have to be
pliant this is self. withth self.
Battle
self
clear almost done few more
errors and not assign type float to int
uh
okay cannot
assign that's pretty funny because you
would be able to do that and see just
fine it would cast it for
go
my Hong mode
eval
discreet no attribute
this should
[Music]
be
default use the default
policy there should be a default
policy D my pong not defined yada yada
yada on Dot
my look at
that random
yeah this is like the typ of thing we
want
workers
512 24
instances and 512 is fine
checkpoint
interval batch size is going to
be
uh
32k I don't
know mini batch size can
be six for while I care
8192 and false and get rid of all this
[Music]
garbage then Cuda
I'm going to give um I'm going to give
this to Nathan is a task to like get him
to make it
files Source
map memory doesn't need this
upper
[Music]
where's the bloody in where are the
bloody
DS then
we build for web
right yeah there we go there's pong on
the web
what do you guys think should I put this
on the
web just add this to puffer
build Docker puffer
[Music]
Docker or.
GG Docs
pong
then we will go
to uh we need a thumbnail of this don't
we long
game
okay this is
then we're just going to do
copy uh Mount
user on
thumbnail
dot for tank
uper
PG Docs
going
okay almost done almost have the silly
thing on the
web
uh what we'll
thil whatever I think this should
work um
pass there's no build we just uh oh we
need to change the index HTML
file to
add an additional thing don't
we let me pull this up locally real
quick
uh
snake the next
one this goes here
on
look at
on look at that uh it doesn't load that's a
problem assets p long
game what do you think about
the they claim to increase
reasoning uh I mean they claim to
increase reasoning dramatically by using
reinforcement
learning
so that sounds good by me maybe some
more people will look at RL now
right that's what happened
I think that's hype yeah well it's hype
for RL we'll see how hype uh the GPT is
maybe it's all just hype right we don't
know
yet but I'm basically going to just keep
doing what I'm doing
why does this not load maybe wait does
this load oh yeah none of them load like
this this is fine this needs to
be uh python mttp do
server then we just go Local Host and
then we click this and now we can play
the game we're happy
[Music]
okay status get add index get commit add
Cort of Nathan's long
game
man
po there we go so we've just put this
game
online uh that'll be in just a second
and I'm about upload the source code for
it pong. c pong. h song IX
b.p build web build
local build see H Pi it's
good
environment porch
oops up
long
setup config ocean
long they did train with specific tasks
like chess with
RL increase I mean they did a lot like
they said a lot of it was RL so
I don't know the like it it really
doesn't affect me as the thing like the
other way of looking at it is like they
made a huge advancement but at the same
time they introduced exponential cost
scaling inference time compute right
they introduced exponentially more
expensive
AI um so I'm going to be very happy just
chilling here training my like basically
free
models and yeah good good day to be me
this I ported his entire thing to see in
like two hours no less than two
hours that was like I mean it was mostly
boiler plate but still that was like
freaking 600 lines of
all right well uh that's one environment
done should I start on
breakout or should I pause and like
think about some stuff
that's a solid little 2hour gig
though um it's
breakout I can find let me see if I can
find Noah's code for for
should be up here
somewhere yeah
well I say we start on
it in like 15 minutes or so I'm going to
probably take a second to order
dinner but yeah here here's what we'll
do I'm going to use the restroom real
quick and then uh we're going to start
on the C breakout
Port maybe we can get it online today I
doubt we'll get it online tonight but
it'll be very close and then we'll like
finish that on Monday and we'll have a
lot of cool stuff for next week all
right so I will uh I'll be right
okay let's let's see how fast I can get
this maybe we can at least get the C
version of this done
today I mean we did just make this pong
so it should be like one to one the same
structure pretty much in fact here this
is what we'll
do copy d r pong Breakout
um breakout move long. h breakout. h
breakout.
h and I think we're going to just start
from here oops that
okay standard lib math pretty standard
stuff this goes at the
top just go hash
Define
nope these go
[Music]
away class
breakout okay all this stuff is going to
be a struct
and like this it's going to be type
def
cor uh let just going to be like see
breakout breakout like
this and
he madlad vectorized it
[Music]
internally is there any benefit to doing
it this
so not substantially at
least I think it's cleaner to have it be
in form so we're going to just have to
do
float
observations
DS uh rewards in
scores episode
[Music]
returns
reward yeah we'll leave them like this
for now load star ball positions and
then yeah there we
okay
um what happened
here
go now we have breakout which has it
freaking crazy signature
um this has to
be the breakout star in it C
breakout with this signature
right God that's
awful but it's okay we're basically the
plan for right now in case it's not
clear is to just ignore how freaking
awful and boiler plate uh this is and
then once we have this the snake the and
uh that will be enough data points for
me to look at and see if I can come up
with a nice way to
redesign but I don't want to try to like
think about it before I can clearly see
what it looks like what the what stuff
is getting
repeated in case that's not
obvious so now we have C breakout
EnV uh and now we just have to
do
breakout star
and
okay and now we just tab all these
things at least for the time
[Music]
redundant turn
n
void compute
[Music]
observations and this is just going to
be
why
it's that's disgusting that it like it
will just come up
with random [ __ ] to paste here balls
zero
balls metal widths
States okay that's observations
done way to
idx we don't need to do it this way
though if num balls
Qui
States for
oops uh this does not need to take in
actions like this this is an
error this is a pretty substantial error
actually in the
code what you do is you
do up here
unsigned charar
actions right and then this is just
going to get set in uh in the init
function
okay uh and we'll just start by doing n
forward 0
0 and then we do
skip substeps I don't know what this num
substep thing is but whatever if action
is no
op
pass
um that is an error because that will
continue
[Music]
this I mean it's not an error it's just
weird
action
left do
this
okay and then what we do is this inside
the loop or outside the loop it's
outside the
loop we just do handle brick collisions
this is very
weird am I misreading
this uh that's a very weird way of on
lining code
but it's fine I get what it it
does then we just do n ball positions
add the
velocity cool and then this is
unindented one
level so then we just do
if good then um balls goes to zero and
then we
do
four done
then it auto resets
interesting we do compute observations
actually where's this kid
applied frame
skip yeah this is a double unindent
wait this is there cuz it's after this
for Loop and then this is here it's
after this for Loop okay
and then we do
[Music]
inline
pool check Collision
discreet does this have self in
it it literally doesn't have self in
self so this is just uh just a little
inline method this is
fine uh this one here does use the
state uh so this is a
bull this does not need the agent index
okay so we just need to uh to format
this
essentially okay so there you go there's
your relative
[Music]
intersection minus
okay this is just a quick and a very
quick and dirty Port after all
here wait
M all
velocities if this then you get the
relative
intersection negative base
angle s cosine
where the [ __ ] did it come up with this
[ __ ] stupid
llms uh this is why you have to not let
them do [ __ ] for
=
64 we do
oops okay this is fine
and now this is return
false sheez this is H something
here I got to order my food I'm going to
keep working on this until it gets here
but I got to order food
uh yeah this we just need to these
there's nothing hard here it's just not
messing up these
ridiculous uh long checks
discreet thanks for working on this is
it just
you uh well I mean puffer is technically
a company I am the main you know core
Deva on the project um this here this is
me porting an open- Source contributors
version of breakout in scyon to Native C
so that we can run it on web and include
it nicely with a bunch of
stuff uh here I'll show you what I just
did today so I just before this I ported
a different contributor's pong game so
now this runs on the web and this trains
Ultra fast as well
uh we still have to fix a couple bugs
the code is longer than it should be but
the goal is that we're going to replace
all of the Annoying RL environments that
are way too slow to work with with just
Ultra Ultra fast really easy to use ones
render on web if you want them to render
his desktop apps if you want him to
basically everything is just nice
insane um there's also the puff recour
stuff which is separate uh and yeah I
mean for the most part I'm doing the dev
on stuff but if you want to check out a
couple fun demos Huffer
GG I'm pretty much always just streaming
Dev yeah it should be
um I think we're very very close to
having the whole field just back on its
feet as soon as we get like a decent
collection of environments that are fast
like with all the other infro that
puffer has um training is going going to
go from on average a few thousand steps
per second to an average of a few
hundred, steps per second so we're just
going to 100x the speed of the field uh
at least the academic research portion
of it a lot of Industry research can
benefit from it as well to be fair so
that is the current plan and that might
seem ambitious but I think we are quite
well on the way to accomplishing it at
this
point uh what am I doing here Collision
top
wall yeah it's just formatting it weird
it should be like this
maybe yeah that'll Port that should just
Auto Port for
me as long as I'm checking it for errors
and making sure it's not going off the
rails with the format but this looks
correct to
me we return
false like this breakout environment for
instance um Atari typically will train
at well it depends what implementation
you're looking at but usually like
thousands of steps per second um the
pong of the pong implementation with
next to no tuning already trans at
200,000 on my local desktop here uh will
be able to very easily get it over a
million steps per second on a better
machine with a little bit of tuning and
the same is going to be true of breakout
so the simpler environments there's no
reason that we shouldn't be training
stuff at a million steps per second it's
it's honestly
embarrassing like that we've just put no
effort into making these things fast
there we go that's a correct Loop
Port
continue uh did it do this check correct
did
yeah that looks like it's good
and this it went off the rails here you
can see
score and then this is determine
Collision Direction
right this should be returned false at
the bottom of all
this
is
here and that is it this is all stuff
from my previous
renderer so this is 316 lines a little
longer than uh long
was still not ridiculous some of the
code is a little
it I'm
assuming uh and I think it shouldn't be
that bad right Raab client yeah this is
Tiny look at this this is all the render
code that we should
struct
St paste
height yeah this is
garbage width height yeah it tried to
copy this from uh the previous
code into num brick
rows yeah you see it's trying to like
copy [ __ ] from from the previous
welcome currently we are porting uh
breakout from a contributor scon version
of breakout to Native C so that we can
run it online next to like this demo and
stuff and then we will we'll have RL
agents trained on this version and we'll
be able to run them online as
well it's pretty
positions it shouldn't need brick
positions
right yeah it should be able to get that
it should be able to get the brick
positions from um from the game
do
[Music]
color Bri colors
four that's fine
uh running
false this is
fine put this at the top of the render
code like here
maybe and
then do client make
client allocate the client set all the
variables
that Returns the
client that's not quite going to cut it
though we need to do a few other things
in
here like initializing the
window knit
window
width
breakout super Maven I'm begging you to
stop giving me bad
[Music]
Corrections set Target
FPS we I don't know what we'll set this
to
but Sprite sheet they don't use puffer
chars
anywhere uh we can do the sound
path potentially we will let's save this
for let's save save this in case we want
it we might actually want this hit sound
that's kind of cool that they use that
they uh they put a hit sound on this no
I mean he put a hit
sound let's do like
this uh void render
this is a little bit
sketchy um you shouldn't need all these
things you should just need the client
you should just need like the
environment that's fine I see the way he
did it
though uh begin drawing clear
background draw a paddle
in paddle
X and paddle
XY zero paddle
y raw
rectangle jeez I don't know why it's
this should be paddle
X PD y paddle width paddle
height and then this should be dark
gray this can be since this doesn't have
any inline math think can we on line
this not
quite the on line is kind of long little
two line
maybe is fine
good he was going to make the uh that's
so funny he was going to make the puffer
the ball we should totally do that we
should make the puffer fish the ball for
these
games that would be hilarious
I'm definitely doing that that's I I
don't know why I didn't think of that
that's
amazing I'm sure I'll regret just having
this copy paste like this but it's
fine is it possible to take advantage of
puffer for reinforcement learning
projects immediately yes of
course uh LM and
interpretability like to explore rl's
personal projects yes so for personal
projects absolutely uh we have a number
of we have bindings for like all the
typical environments that you're
familiar with uh they're going to run
faster in puffer lib than just about
anything else uh puffer lib is going to
be simpler than every other Library out
there except for clean RL clean RL is
going to be simpler but uh you know we
get as close as possible possible to
that while also giving you the
performance uh and we also provide the
best support out there cuz you can
literally just ask me stuff on stream CU
I'm constantly streaming and uh there's
also a Discord and there's a whole bunch
of helpful people in there as well so
yeah I hope the project is useful to you
and if it is don't forget to feed the
puff or a star on GitHub helps us out a
lot
running fast in support
yeah this let me give you just a little
example this MOA here I don't know if
you've played Dota or League of Legends
this is like a little mini mooba this is
a work in progress
environment but like this is we already
have like Fast support for all the
existing environments in RL but we got
everything to be so fast that we're
bottlenecked on all of the environment
Sim speeds so this environment here is
like a MOA it has a bunch of the
features of like leag or DOTA it's got
minions it's got creep waves it's got
neutrals it's got Heroes it's got
abilities this thing runs a million
steps per second per CPU core simulation
and I currently have this thing training
at like a half million steps per second
on one GPU we can probably go faster as
well so that's where puffer's going
where it is now already is uh well all
the existing environments you can run
them faster on tougher than basically
anywhere else
soon nice going to have to get some
going to have to get back to some
experiments but return next time sure
thanks for dropping by for
good did I not make
allocate I didn't make
allocate
actions D why does it do all this
there's no way there's this much
right yeah this thing is like giving me
garbage you just need like float star
actions float star
observations DS reward scores
returns B position
velocities je there are actually a lot
of
freaking pointers in this bloody
thing ball
speeds it counters okay but then it
starts hallucinating after
do is puffer like
maoko no so um puffer is a that you can
use majoko with and you'll be able to
run majoko faster than if you were to
use like native gymnasium vectorization
or whatever is included in most common
libraries uh you can use it with just
about any environment out there and we
provide tools to make complex
environment simple to work with just
about any environment out there much
faster than it would be otherwise when
you simulate multiples distributed um
and also we we provide a lot of like
nice utilities and stuff and then this
stuff you're seeing me Dev here we're
starting to create our own custom
environments to replace existing ones
that just run like 100 to a thousand
times faster you can see a couple of
these in progress on puffer
Dogg I'll show
you we've got like a little
showcase so like here snake running in
your browser with a bunch of snakes and
a bunch of Agents we've got pong this is
I just added this this today and then if
you want like more complicated M's
here's a miniature version of DOTA that
I've been
developing with a bunch of different
hero classes right plays like uh little
mooba so yeah puffer is a lot of
things it's really mainly just my effort
as now that I've graduated to make
reinforcement learning fast
organization Google summer of code am I
wait what is
uh
so the thing with this is like I don't
know what level the contributors are
here but like
we so I take for people who contribute
to puffer we take people who are like
new to AI or like new to reinforcement
learning right but not people who are
new to programming as a whole as often
we have a couple who have done very well
who came in with no experience on like
like Pokemon for instance um but
generally you do need to have like
substantial programming experience and
if you don't have like RL experience for
instance that's okay but I think the
level might not match exactly I applied
dqn and D dqn on a cust immunity search
and retrieve environment help of ml
agents training time for 1,000 steps was
two days that's
insane yeah there's literally like you
can't learn anything at that
rate yeah no our environments are are
like the new environments that we're
adding are a minimum of a million steps
per second um and even when we get more
complex like really really complex I'm
confident we're going to still be in
like the hundreds of thousands of steps
per second and that's per single CPU
core um yeah it's the performance that
we're talking about here is a completely
different
league and I mean you can see we're not
limited by the complexity of what we can
develop either like I'm missing some
fancy animations cuz I don't have the
artwork yet
right um but like this is a freaking MOA
like this is like miniature Dota or
League of Legends like you know this is
way more complicated than Atari or like
most of the simple environments people
are using in research and it still runs
crazy fast so like we're not limited At
All by the complexity of what we can
do how can I help you except starring
the
repo I mean if you want to if you're in
the RL space and want to contribute
stuff uh that's cool if you just want to
use Li for your repo and you know spread
the word to your colleagues that's also
cool I mean the main thing for us is
just having satisfied users at this
point and growing out the project so um
you know if you're in Academia tell your
colleagues about it right if you find
bugs in puffer lib come report them so
that I can make stuff better uh
eventually the way that we scale this
out and make puffer lib like successful
um is for folks in Academia we'll be
selling um support packages to them but
that's not really applicable if you're
in Academia whatsoever it's all free an
open source want to contribute to RL I'm
undergrad well great I mean um there are
a few things you can do it depends on
what level of stuff you want to get
involved in so
this this environment here this breakout
environment was written by a contributor
without a ton of Prior RL experience
this pong environment was also written
by where is it the pong environment was
also written by a
contributor it's not that hard to make
these types of
simulations uh you can write them in C
or you can just write them in scon scon
is like python it's very
easy and we mainly we want more
simulators right now but we also just
want people doing research with puffer
so if you want to learn some like super
ultra high perf simulation Dev you're
free to help there if you just want to
use puffer for research and like you
know spread the word get some stuff out
there that's also cool that's pretty
much where we're going with
this I started RL in undergrad as well
that's like eight years ago
now was a hard field to get into and
it's still a hard field to get into but
I'm trying to make it easier
this I lost my tab math prere is much
more no the math prere is actually very
very little um you really don't need
much math at all like whatsoever for uh
reinforcement learning what you do need
is you need more engineering skill you
need much much much more engineering
skill than you need in any other area of
AI like it's the most engineering
intensive area of AI total outside of
like the people who are scaling stuff on
the massive clusters uh outside of that
this is like the hardest engineering
area of AI I've worked in all of them so
I can say that confidently
is it's actually pretty funny because
like they're all these fancy algorithms
and um n RL now but like we've kind of
just been crushing everything with po
plus like ultra high perf Sims and good
hyper parameter sweeps and
stuff the progress has been pretty
awesome okay so we need these parameters
right
oh
jeez crazy
there constants in
here there
six brick
rows brick
with
height
generate brick positions okay so we need
the positions at some
point
yeah
tricky so will be frame skip DT no
substeps
height
okay there million things wrong with
this I'm
[Music]
sure snake.
C probably want this one
or the
actions do not make this human
P up
is
one qy left is two Q right is
three
perfect we allocated
breakout uh I just saw your thing there
are no mountain car cart pole
environment yeah there well there are um
there's the initial binding like we have
the classic like cartpole Ms and stuff
um if you want to like make one like as
a standalone for this you can do that I
think those are already very fast though
I'm pretty sure like those Ms are
already very very
fast I guess they don't render as
cleanly and stuff but yeah if you want
if you just want like a simple thing to
do as an exercise and like to have like
a standalone and tougher and like to
make something convenient to use sure
you can do like a mountain car type
thing
sure um I'm trying to think if there any
other classic environments that people
use that are like simple to implement as
a starting project or an undergrad
um what's like something that's like
simple but not
trivial gem
open I'm gonna have to go grab my food
as well very soon let me see if I can
find you something and uh make sure you
join the Discord it's
discord.gg
puffer is this a thing
here this is Atari M isn't
control yeah I think that the Box 2D
environments are probably a good
starting point
cuz these are really really slow I think
yeah it gives you pixel
OBS you don't want pixel OBS you just
want State
observations yeah so I think that these
would be like good ones uh these would
definitely be good ones to
use cuz these box 2D environments are so
slow and so
obnoxious so like pick your favorite of
these pick whichever looks easiest to
you um and then I don't just like go
randomly Implement stuff though without
any guidelines like the easiest thing to
do is if you look at our Dev
Branch I just added pong to this
um so look there's
like where is it so if you look at snake
there's a scon version here scon should
be very easy for you to get a hold of if
you know python it's the same thing you
just add types and then it makes it fast
um the main thing is that we use uh we
use rib for rendering rayb is really
nice and convenient and you have example
code here I don't know what your
experience is if you want to go lower
level there's also a c
version uh and puffer
Leb there's also a c version that we use
and that's what we're everything
eventually goes to C because it's just
easy you can code and see awesome are
you comfortable in it though or is it
like you've you just took it for like a
class I don't mean to offend you it's
just like I know when I was an undergrad
I like I took it as a class but uh I
didn't really do much with
it for a class well then whatever you
feel more comfortable in I'll say
um I don't want you to get like
overwhelmed with stuff but I like just
look through the code in Ocean
specifically ocean is first party
environments you can see like snake here
uh there is
a there's a python version here so it's
just snake and python there's like scyon
code and then there's the purec
version you can do whatever
the main thing that's helpful is if you
get like really simple code where you
accurately reproduce the Dynamics of the
environment right and you make it really
simple and you don't use like a bunch of
like dict and like list data structures
if you just do everything in static
arrays right then it's very easy for me
to port to see and it saves us a bunch
of
time food's here in a couple minutes but
I'll answer a couple questions until it
gets there
syon is just as fast as c as well the
only reason that I do c one is I like it
and the other the big reason I do c is
because I can do this and I just put
them online trivially C compiles to web
assembly and at least for me it's not
any hard
I do with
here
weird counters
he lots of work I can't believe I forgot
about these until just now like yeah
these are such classic environments they
should be very simple to implement as
well I guess it technically has like
basic physics
oh look at
this you can actually use box
2D
C so I guess for like a bipedal Walker
will be very difficult to do without
having the physics engine maybe the like
maybe lunar lander or the car wouldn't
be I don't know but yeah this is
cool yeah you can do lunar lander that's
good you're allowed to use box 2D for it
as well because it's in
C
files oh yeah yeah look it's just a very
simple Bo it's a very nice simple C
thing okay this is really nice I didn't
realize this was in
C that's actually
awesome like it's
what do they use for rendering
then honestly if you want to do if you
want to make stuff really easy on
yourself just to get just to get into
yeah yeah so there is actually like
there are some Dynamics to this thing
actually I thought it would be simpler
than this
State yeah if you want to just like get
rid of py game I think the easiest thing
to do will just be to take this
code replace this shitty P game renderer
with one in RB that'll be better and
then just like start simplifying and
stripping you know dependencies out of
this if we can just get us a standalone
of this
because my hope is that what we'll be
able to do eventually is we can like
start porting this lower
level like this library is in C so like
we can move we can move the Dynamics
into scon then we can move that into C
eventually and then this will all be way
simpler this might be kind of hard so I
wouldn't just like try to write like
rewrite this from scratch on your own or
anything there's actually quite a lot of
physics in here that you have to get
right but you can definitely replace
rendering and
such if that's too hard pick a simpler
environment but um yeah if that's too
hard you can pick a simpler one for sure
I will be back on uh on Monday I usually
stream like uh afternoon through evening
Pacific most days of the week so feel
free to drop by
discord.gg puffer to join and uh I also
post a bunch of stuff on Twitter it's
jars
5341 anyways you have a nice
evening no someone has to do it also I
will learn something very good then the
one thing I will just tell you then is
like make sure that like you
don't like take this logic as is like
you definitely want to take this logic
as is and just Port it directly like you
don't want to try to rewrite from
scratch because there's a lot of physics
and stuff in here that can go wrong
start by start by replacing the renderer
with rib that will be way faster and
won't have the shitty pie game
dependency that'll make it a lot easier
for you to learn and get a little bit of
intuition about the environment uh then
from there this stuff can start to go
into scon maybe um and then from there
it can go into C that should be pretty
clean yeah that should be
nice all right you have a nice evening
catch you around and I hope